My name is Mary Yuan...
...and I'm a senior public relations manager in corporate communications at AT&T.
I think my favorite part about working here is probably the environment.
It's a really, really fast-paced environment, but it's also really collaborative.
And so you have a lot of people with different expertise all working together...
...and so you really get a taste of different parts of corporate communications.
And so when you're putting together a plan, you have all of these unique perspectives...
...that really makes the overall plan a much better one.
So, I think the collaborative environment and all of these people...
...who are coming from different backgrounds really make it fun to work here.